invité pour un face à face en ce 26
février sur tv fils bertrand réveillon
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le bienvenu
sur ce plateau c'est un peu particulier
de vous recevoir puisque vous avez été
il ya plus d'une quinzaine d'années avec
twizy est très très anciens
c'est une vie antérieure effectivement
c'est pas pour ça que vous êtes la venue
sur le plateau ce soir c'est pour
évoquer un ouvrage conversation
spirituel un recueil de vos entretiens
avec des personnalités de patrick poivre
d'arvor agents giraudeau par exemple il
se livre sur leurs convictions et leurs
croyances des entretiens que vous aviez
déjà publié un dans le magazine chrétien
panorama et dont vous étiez d'ailleurs
directeur de la rédaction alors pourquoi
avoir compilé ces différents échanges et
puis surtout à quel public s'adresse pas
uniquement des chrétiens ah non non non
pas du tout c'est la question de dieu c
est dieu dans tout ça pose et à des
croyants et des non croyants des
agnostiques à des juifs des musulmans à
des athées des chrétiens avec des
protestants voilà c'est une question qui
intéresse je me suis rendu compte que
effectivement il n'y a pas de difficulté
à ouvrir la question spirituelle au sens
large la question de la philosophie de
l'existence avec des hommes et des
femmes très connu qui a une vingtaine
d'entretiens dans cette compilation on
va dire mais vous en avez réalisé
combien des entretiens sur ce thème est
qu il y en a perçu en fait d'un côté
j'ai pas compter et en a mis énormément
et je préfère ne pas compter comment
s'est fait le choix en revanche pour
ceux pour cet ouvrage pour cet ouvrage
on appris le principe était simple on a
pris les personnaliser les plus célèbres
donc essentiellement le monde artistique
et un peu journalistique que vous avez
décidé donc de mettre en avant pour
autant il est difficile de faire parler
véritablement les différents
interlocuteurs de leurs croyances de
leurs convictions
déjà dans la préface qui est signée par
eric emmanuel schmitt on peut lire que
justement il le dit c'est courant on est
souvent peut-être moquer même lorsqu'on
évoque sa foi lorsqu on assume son
christianisme est ce que vous êtes
d'accord
non je pense que c'est même devenu
tendance de parler de spiritualité je
travaille aujourd'hui pour un grand
magazine qui s'appelle psychologies
magazine qui n'est pas du tout un
journal chrétien
et il ya une rubrique de spiritualité en
fin de journal que j'anime tous les mois
et je n'ai aucune difficulté à parler de
ces questions avec des gens de toutes
convictions mais à des gens qui ont
parfois du mal à franchir le pas juste
d'évoquer parce que c'est vrai lorsque
nous avons discuté avant que vous veniez
sur ce plateau vous m'avez évoqué le cas
de michel rocard justement l'ancien
ministre michel rocard il n'est pas dans
le livre il est il est dans son lit il
dit dans un précédent alors ses sincères
sentiments une anecdote amusante à dire
que michel rocard me reçoit dans son
bureau parisien
son assistante n'avait pas dû lui dire
qu'elle était l'objet de l'entretien
je m'assieds en face de lui et je lui
dis on va parler de dieu il dit pas
question
il est hors de question je vous parle il
est protestant d'origine michel rocard
il m'a dit je parlerai pas de ça je suis
embêté parce que j'ai réservé six pages
dans mon journal que fait-on mehdi bon
un quart d'heure je dis dieu en un quart
d'heure ça va pas le faire et finalement
on a parlé 1h15
j'ai éteint le magnéto il m'a regardé il
a roulé les yeux et me dise à l'opa ce
sont des entretiens peut-être les plus
intéressants ceux qui sont les plus
difficiles à aller chercher ce qui est
très intéressant c'est de d'être face à
des hommes et des femmes qui vous
réussit pas le catéchisme qui vous
disent pas je suis croyant je suis sûr
de ma foi ce qui me passionne c'est les
gens qui cherchent c'est les hommes et
les femmes qui cherchent voilà en
tâtonnant en se disant j'y crois un peu
j'y crois pas beaucoup je cherche je
remets en question j'avance voilà c'est
les gens chemin qui m'intéresse mais
l'ajustement par exemple ce type de
profils de personnes qui s'interrogent
et qui doutent aussi bernard pivot en
revanche son d'entretien l'entretien que
vous avez réalisé avec lui et dans cet
ouvrage conversation spirituel l'huile
doute beaucoup et tout beaucoup et on a
joué le jeu vraiment je lui pose une
question de questions trois questions
j'essaie de le cerner pour savoir et
effectivement il est je crois agnostique
c'est quelqu'un qui a grandi dans une
culture chrétienne qui s'en est un peu
détaché mais qui reste intéressé qui je
crois le restera jusqu'à sa demande dans
quel état d'esprit vous êtes lorsque
vous réalisez ces différents entretiens
justement parce que vous êtes
journaliste média croci donc vous avez
vos convictions vos croyances
lorsque vous rencontrez des personnages
comme bernard pivot par exemple qui
doutent alors il ya deux choses il ya le
métier et puis après il ya le privé
parce que forcément il ya un lien entre
les deux le métier je suis ouvert à
toutes les convictions tout les toutes
les paroles toutes les manières de
s'exprimer sur ces questions là j'ai
rencontré il ya un livre qui vient de
sortir sur françois giroux je me
souviens d'avoir rencontré françoise
giroud il ya des années qui à toutes les
questions me disais je ne crois
absolument en rien le ciel est vide
j'irai au cimetière il ne se passe rien
après voilà donc respecter la conviction
des hommes et des femmes que je
rencontre pas cherché à les convertir ou
alors dire vous avez tort vous avez
raison peu importe
après quand le magnéto était est éteint
et qu'on a parlé pendant une heure et
demie de questions fondamentales avec
ces hommes et ces femmes se passe
parfois une alchimie qui fait qu'on se
revoie et on se revoit et là c'est
plutôt ma mon engagement diaconale ou là
je continue à revoir un certain nombre
de personnes par exemple j'ai été en
contact jusqu'à sa mort avec bernard
giraudeau avec qui j'avais il ya une
amitié
c'était of voilà lorsque vous menez ces
différents entretiens ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est la façon dont
vous amener les différentes
personnalités ou moins connu est les
personnes que vous rencontrez vous leur
faites parler de leur passé bien souvent
ça passe par des anecdotes de leur passé
des moments forts de leur existence elle
est encore dense parler de leurs
croyances on est encore dans un pays où
les les une certaine génération
d'artistes a reçu une culture religieuse
qu'elle soit chrétienne qu'elle soit
juive
voilà pour l'essentiel ces hommes et ces
femmes ont approché la foi et donc c'est
toujours intéressant de voir comment ils
se positionnent par rapport à une fois
reçu de l'enfance qui la rejette ou
qu'ils la fassent évoluer
il ya différents entretiens qui sont
compilés il ya certes un entretien que
vous n'avez pas pu réaliser ça fait
partie peut-être des regrets c'est aussi
intéressant d'en parler j'aimerais juste
qu'on voit une des photos d'une des
personnalités que vous auriez aimé
rencontrer
c'est notamment georges brassens georges
brassens à noël je vous auriez selon
rencontrer saint georges brassens gelé
j'ai eu son secrétaire particulier
au téléphone quelques semaines avant sa
mort et je n'ai pas réussi à le
rencontrer il ya également je voulais
raconter ça au téléphone l'autre jour il
ya 20 ans yves montand lors l'anecdote
est savoureuse
un soir le téléphone sonne chez moi ma
femme décroche elle met la main sur
l'écouteur et elle me dit il ya encore
un des copains qui te fait une blague et
qui se fait passer pour yves montand et
c'était réellement il montre voilà et
manque de chance il est mort pendant un
tournage et je ne vais pas rencontrer ce
n'est pas vain des entretiens que vous
pourrez retrouver dans ce livre
conversations spirituel mais il y en a
bien d'autres un jean d'ormesson patrick
poivre d'arvor bernard giraudeau aussi
quelle est la personnalité qui vous a
peut-être le plus marqué dans les
différentes rencontres que le public
peut découvrir ou redécouvrir dans cette
compilation crois que c'est bernard
giraudeau bernard giraudeau et était
atteint d'un cancer très grave avec
récidive il se posait beaucoup de
questions il était protestant d'origine
il avait il était très intéressé par le
bouddhisme
je crois que l'une des dernières
questions qui m'a demandé c'était de
savoir où il pourrait faire une retraite
dans un monastère
voilà ça c'est des souvenirs très forts
on va parler également de vous de votre
parcours et j'aimerais vous faire
écouter un extrait sonore s'il ya la
possibilité de lancer cette petite
séquence et vous allez me dire ce que ça
vous évoque aussi et puis pourquoi c'est
important pour vous
'pour radioscopie jacques chancel jacent
jacques chancel mon père mon maître
voilà ma mère est écoutée radioscopie à
la maison et de temps en temps j'ai
écouté avec elle l'émission et j'étais
fasciné par cet homme qui avait le droit
de poser toutes les questions les plus
indiscrètes
c'est un fabuleux métier un métier que
nous faisons voilà posé toutes les
questions les plus indiscrètes pendant
une heure c'était un temps cette
émission radioscopie c'est ça qui allait
donc notablement je me suis dit un jour
je vais pas être à sa place parce que
j'étais pas orgueilleux à ce point mais
je vais faire le même métier
et alors ce qui est amusant c'est que 20
ans plus tard
j'ai rencontré jacques chancel on est
devenus amis et l'ancêtre le précédent
tome de cet ouvrage est préfacé de
jacques chancel voilà la boucle est
bouclée
vous avez travaillé pour la croix pour
panorama vous collaborez aujourd'hui
pour psychologies magazine vous l'avez
mentionné vous avez travaillé aussi pour
france télévisions en france 2 aux
mornes l'a5 donc aussi bien télévision
que que presse écrite votre préférence
va à quel média par rapport notamment
aux entretiens que vous pouvez réaliser
c'est peut-être plus facile d'obtenir
des confidences on va dire que les gens
se livrent par écrit c'est vrai que par
écrit il ya un travail de moi je fais
toujours relire
donc on peut aller dans l'ain team parce
que on dit à la personne en interview
vous pourrez relire vous inquiétez pas
vous inquiétez pas et en fait
généralement ils s il laisse les choses
en l'état et donc c'est passionnant mais
le média télévisé est un média chaud
affectif il se passe des choses ou les
une anecdote j'ai présenté une émission
avant la messe télévisée le dimanche
matin et un jour je reçois robert
hossein
il y avait un second invité qui venaient
en vedette américaine et il me dit est
ce que ça tu en 8 faire venir frédéric
dard le père de san antonio
voilà donc j'ai quand même réussi ce
coup de faire venir avant la messe
télévision le patron de san antonio
alors il publier un dictionnaire et il y
avait au centre les pages roses
je vous laisse deviner ce qu'il y avait
dans le dictionnaire dans les pages
roses de san antonio
voilà ça on a bien respectivement sa
réserve quelques moments particuliers
dans ces cas-là on le disait vous êtes
journaliste aussi diacre à quel moment
se sont croisés c'est aussi bien cette
vie personnelle en privé que ce métier
véritablement de journalistes à quel
moment c'est rentrer dans votre vie
professionnelle a compté un jour
des chrétiens m'ont demandé
de d'assurer une présence voilà le monde
des médias le monde des artistes est un
monde un peu particulier sont des hommes
et des femmes qui bien souvent pour des
raisons personnelles d'histoires
personnelles sont très loin des églises
et ont un peu de mal à les voir un curé
du coin parce que tout le monde le
reconnaît
donc je suis mon job diaconale mon
engagement diaconale c'est d'être
envoyée auprès de ces hommes et ces
femmes pas pour les convertir mais pour
partager un peu leur vie si je vous pose
cette question de votre engagement
religieux aussi c'est parce que je sais
que cette question quel prochaine
échange vous aimeriez réaliser vous
allez me répondre le prochain pas ben ça
serait le scoop ça quand même des alors
voir le père joe papp
parce que le prochain pas que c'est
toujours intéressant de savoir ce qu'il
a à dire
finalement il a serré la première
question vous lui poseriez je lui
demanderais avec beaucoup de respect
comment il compte s'y prendre pour
plonger enfin l'église catholique dans
la modernité c'est à dire que vous êtes
assez critique avec le bilan sont peut
faire un bilan de ces différentes années
de benoît sel quand on est de la famille
on peut se permettre de dire des choses
voilà je suis résolument de la famille
je pense que l'église pourrait évoluer
sur un certain nombre de questions est
faux de penser à la place des femmes
je pense
à la place des femmes dans la
gouvernance je pense aux divorcés
remariés voilà il ya un certain nombre
de questions qui pourraient quand même
un jour évoluer
j'espère que vous pourrez le rencontrer
pour lui poser toutes ces questions on
est très curieux de découvrir les
réponses peut-être dans le prochain tome
saleh qui n'est personne et le pat
le pape ne répond jamais peut-être
quelques talents s'il évolue et s'il se
modernise pourquoi pas ce serait
l'occasion merci à vous encore des
traits sur le plateau conversation
spirituel aux éditions aux éditions
médiaspaul voilà on en voit la
couverture disponible à saint quentin en
yvelines a notamment librairie lettres
voisine et puis aux pavés du canal merci
à vous et sert cité dans une collection
que vous dirigez wii n'a pas eu
l'occasion de le mentionner
je vous retrouve demain à 18 heures en
direct sur ce plateau avec de nouveaux
invités nous parlerons des 30 ans de l
accompagner local de danse black blanc
beur avec son fondateur jean dauger mad
et nous parlons aussi de l'initiative du
club fast ou saint quentin en yvelines
qui apprend aux élèves à mieux
appréhender le monde du travail
l'entreprise renault implantée à saint
quentin est notamment partenaire je vous
souhaite une excellente soirée sur notre
antenne
moutet